- So Alyson, I'm loving this,
like, American Pie Reunion.
- Me too.
- But here's my question.
- Yes.
- Do people still walk up to you
and say, "this one time at band camp"?
- Yes, they do.
(audience laughs)
Which is lovely to be associated
with the movie people still know,
but I have two daughters now
and when they're with me
and they like when--
- People don't
follow through, right?
- Somebody starts saying the line,
I'm like, "could we just stop there?"
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- Like, yes, like I'm
not, I get really panicked
I'm like.
- Of course.
- Yeah, I know what you're talking about,
- Yeah.
- They don't.
- Yeah, really funny.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- I don't wanna have this
conversation with them yet.
- I've never thought about
that, 'cause you have kids.
- Yeah.
- That's, well wait, you
have kids too though,
so, like, wait when it came
out did your kids see it?
- No.
(laughs)
No, my daughter was 12 and so that.
- That's a little early.
- That's a little early,
my son was 15 and he was
going to come with us
in Los Angeles.
We went down for the premier.
- Yeah.
- Of the movie,
and the night before the premier,
he said, he was on a
phone call with his friend
back in Toronto, and they
said, "well what's going on?"
And he said, "Well I'm
going to the premier
"of American Pie tomorrow
night with my folks."
And the friend said, "oh
don't see it with your folks."
(laughing)
"Don't see it with your folks.
- Bad move.
- "You don't wanna see
this with your folks."
(laughing)
So he came to us and said, "You know what?
"I think I'm not gonna go tomorrow,
"and I'll see it when I go back
to Toronto with my friends."
And I thought, "oh, well okay,
"it's gonna be a big night."
Meanwhile, we went to the
premier, saw the movie.
I'm so glad he wasn't there.
(laughs)
- [Alyson] Oh.
- That's so awkward.
- Yes.
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
Well what's funny is we
go back like 17 years.
You were at the Idol Finale
when I won.
- I was.
- [Kelly] That is crazy.
- I was my husband.
(audience applauds)
- And yeah, I know.
In fact it was funny because
my husband was working on,
TV show "Angel" at the time,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And he was supposed to be at work.
- I love Angel, I loved Angel.
- Well thanks.
- Yeah.
- He was supposed to work, but
he happened to be chopping,
a chopping, cutting
flowers but with a knife,
which is dumb.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
- And he slit his wrist.
- Wow.
- Luckily, it was okay,
he just had some stitches or whatever,
but they gave him the day off
and I was like, "great, you can come
"to American Idol with me."
But when he went to work the
next day, they were like,
"You faked an injury
just to go see American.
(laughing)
- And he said, "No, no, no, it's really."
Like he had to show the stitches.
(laughing)
But because of that clapping shot.
- We, I'm gonna tell you, it's so funny.
When I found this out, I was like,
we didn't really know
that it was that big,
we were in a bubble, right?
So we didn't know there were like,
there were a lot of celebrities there.
Like, for us, I'm from
like a small town in Texas,
and I was like, "Who's here?"
And like, they started naming.
- Yeah.
- We thought it was the craziest thing,
it was so supportive.
- Shannon Elizabeth was also there.
- I know, yeah.
- We were bawling, we were like,
"She won."
- Me too.
Yeah, I was like, "I
don't have wait tables."
Yeah, that was my thing.
(applauding)
So, and now I hear we're also neighbors,
we both live near each other.
- We do, I know.
- So how would I know your house?
- And that's why I think,
we should become best friends
because--
- I am down.
- Then we could, like borrow sugar.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- So would I know your house?
- Well, you might, like,
because I over decorate,
for Halloween and for like.
- Do you've giant cats in your front yard?
- No, oh I do know that person,
but no
- Oh.
- That's not me.
(laughing)
For Halloween.
- My family we named them.
- Yeah, for Halloween,
I decorated the gate
as, Frankenstein and
Bride of Frankenstein.
- Okay, now I'm gonna go
cruising our neighborhood.
- And yeah, it's it was really yeah.
- I'm gonna be like, "Alyson."
- I go crazy, I do.
- I love decorating as well.
- Yes.
- You're crafty, I hear, as well.
- I love crafting,
- [Kelly] Yes.
- It's like, just it's my happy space.
- [Kelly] It's fun.
- Yes.
- I put on music, I drink some wine.
- See, you could come
over, forget the sugar.
- Okay, forget it.
- Just come craft.
- Let's craft.
- Yes, and, you know, my
daughter's almost old enough
to like babysit your kids.
- See, see.
- In like.
You know what?
Even if she's not,
- Four years.
- I'll let her watch them.
- Okay.
(laughing)
- Fine.
- Awesome.
- Totally fun.
- Yeah.
- So where, where do you
do all of the crafting?
You have like a place in your house?
- So we have a guest
house that I've taken over
and turned it into the craft house.
(gasps)
- I did that to ours for a minute,
and then I had no days off
and so I was like, "well this is useless."
But I did that with ours too.
Its kinda nice.
- [Alyson] Yeah it's also smart.
- 'Cause no one ever uses it.
- No it's smart because then
it, like, keeps guests away.
- Yeah I love you, we
could be friends, okay,
So before we go to break,
tell us about this series Outmatched.
That's where you are right?
- Yes so, Jason Biggs has a new show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's a very small community.
- Very "American Pie"
- And Eddie Kaye Thomas and I,
are gonna be on Jason's show.
So it really is everything.
- Oh.
(applauding)
It's so cool.
- Oh, wow yeah.
(applauding)
- So what's it about?
- It's about, Jason plays
a part of a parent-duo
that has like I think,
(mumbling)
I haven't filmed the show yet.
- [Kelly] Okay, yeah.
- 3 or 4 kids and like
most of them are geniuses
and one isn't, but, so.
- Aww.
- And so they're in, they're just like,
trying to keep up with how
smart their children are.
- Oh my God, and the one kid is like,
you know
- Just normal.
- "I'm creative, you know,
but I offer other things."
- [Alyson] "I eat glue."
- Yeah, "eats glue."
(laughing)
Oh my God.